hello can everybody hear me okay sabacc
okay welcome thank you very much for
coming to my talk for sticking around
for this long I hope you had a great
conference I think I'm recognizing some
of your faces I think maybe I saw some
of you yesterday at lunch the diversity
lunch n so it's great to see you again
to those of you who didn't hear me speak
about my project yesterday which I was
able to shoehorn into a talk about
diversity I am now going to talk about
it you know in more detail so to the
talk today and is visual Diagnostics for
more informed machine learning and here
I hear some ways to find me so um like
Mandy said my name is Rebecca Bilborough
you can tweet at me if you have
questions I'll tweet out these slides
after the talk and my day job is at x
cubed and then my passion project is
working with district data labs and
doing open-source development so I'll
tell you a little bit about my work at x
cubed since they were you know very kind
too kind of sponsor my attendance to
this conference it's a small tech
company in Arlington and I lead a team
of data scientists who are using a bunch
of different kinds of machine learning
tools to basically try to do kind of
like next-generation business analytics
we are hiring if you are interested come
and talk to me it's a very quick paced
place to work and it's a fun group so I
come chat with me if you are curious to
hear more about that
but I also want to talk a little bit
about kind of how I even ended up here
so I've started out as a child as
probably many of you did but in terms of
machine learning my path to machine
learning was sort of circuitous so
basically the first question when you
talk to machine learning people I feel
like the first question they ask you as
do you have a PhD and I do I have a PhD
but it is not in machine learning and
you know so I studied math and then I
studied technical communication and
information visualization and then you
know kind of meandered a lot and ended
up in data science and kind of just fell
in love with machine learning and so I
think part of the reason is because
Python as I'm sure many of you have
noticed the Python makes machine
learning so easy like scarily easy right
it's like four lines of code and you are
machine learning already so that is
exciting when you're getting started you
know you you get to wield all of this
power so quickly you don't even have to
be that good at programming and to be
honest so I sort of wanted to go through
just to convince you if you aren't
already convinced kind of how quick you
can sort of get there from from sort of
soup to nuts getting getting going with
machine learning in Python so I
basically you have to get some data you
have to prepare it you know the
wrangling part you need to pick an
algorithm a model you have to
instantiate and fit that model you
should validate it because you're a nice
person and then you deploy it right so
it's really just as simple as that and
and so to go through in a little bit
more detail kind of how this what this
looks like in practice
is you know when I was getting started
and I think a lot of people sort of
start here right because you go and
there's all of this like curated data
for you it's like even better than
curated it's like manicured data it's
like an English garden of beautiful
little data sets all in a row and it's
very clean it's like ready to use
there's information about you know what
the attributes are what the futures are
it sometimes gives you advice about
which model to even use there's
publications associated with the the
data sets so you know you kind of get
started with one of these data sets
probably if you don't know what model to
pick you ask the internet and all of the
very opinionated people of the internet
eagerly you know sort of answer your
question about what model you should be
using because they have a favorite and
then like I said you know it's like four
lines of code inside KITT learn and
you're going already so I you import
your model you instantiate it you call
fit and then you call predict and that's
it then you like I said we're good
people we know we need to validate our
models so I scikit-learn comes with all
of the metrics that you need you know so
if you're doing regression you're
looking for the mean squared error and
the r-squared score if you're doing a
classification maybe you're looking for
your f1 or you just run a classification
report and it gives you f1 and recall
and precision and then you know maybe
you didn't do as well as you thought so
you use psyche psyche it learns grid
search tool to kind of like grope around
for better hyper parameters and
hopefully you get your scores up and so
you kind of maybe iterate through this a
little bit
then you can deploy it by just you know
the model that you've that you've fit
already you use you use it to predict on
a new X you know your new input and then
you have to figure out how to put it
into a pipeline and it looks kind of
this and then you can deploy it and
basically you're done and you know how
to do machine learning now and that's
really all you have to do so I think
probably like as I'm telling this sort
of version of the narrative I'm seeing
you know recognition in your eyes and
I'm not sure you know this isn't like a
super slick version of the story but I
gather that probably a lot of the
self-taught machine learning
practitioners in the room probably
figured it out this way and I'm not
going to make you raise your hand but I
just can tell from how you're looking at
me um that you know a lot of you guys
started this way right so this is how I
got started to I'm raising my hand so
but the thing is is at some point after
doing this a couple of times I started
sort of feeling like the sick feeling in
my stomach you know like I would like at
night I would look up at the ceiling and
kind of feel like just terror that I was
wielding all this power and I like had
no idea what I was really doing and you
know as a former math major I sort of
felt like maybe I should understand a
little bit better what's happening under
the hood here even though you don't
really have to to kind of just get going
maybe kind of to go to the next level
you you know you do need to have a
little bit better of a sense and I think
that you know this this kind of took me
on a whole different journey from from
the first version and really I think
what I've learned is that you know
machine learning is easy but informative
machine learning is hard
I'm not here to offer you the silver
bullet for that because it doesn't exist
you know people people who are really
good at machine learning you know people
who went to school to study machine
learning studied it for a long time you
know they invested a long time learning
how to do this and you're not going to
figure that out on your own overnight
there's no magic thing that you can
install that will kind of do all the
thinking for you there's no package that
you can outsource the thinking to you
know no matter how slick the graphical
interfaces you know it's not going to do
the thinking for you it's not going to
build your intuition so we just need to
sort of acknowledge that informed
machine learning is going to be hard
right on the other hand I you know we
want to be informed right like we can't
just give up and say alright i'll just
do dumb machine learning then we want to
be informed because machine learning
applications and machine learning is you
know increasingly driving a lot of
decision making more and more
decision-making you know everything from
a sort of wartime operations to like
dating sites so really like a full range
of kind of things are being driven and
being informed by you know machine
learning applications and we want to be
involved in that right that's the tech
that we want to build or or optimized
for spin off of and so we want to make
sure that we are pointing people towards
the right things whether it's the right
bad guys or the right you know special
person I we want to make sure that we
are you know making a you know making
good machine learning decisions so does
anybody recognize this image who knows
what this is
like three people who have been in my
class before I'll know the answer so so
what is it let's go yeah Anscombe is
quartet so the lesson I think for me of
ants comes quartet so Ann screams
quartet if you don't know it's for
synthetic data sets that are meant to
illustrate that you know even if you
kind of even if you end up with data
sets that have very similar kind of
statistical behavior they can be very
different in practice and and maybe you
can't actually see how different they
are until you visualize them and so
here's a terrific example of that these
are four datasets that basically hot you
know if you did like you know dot
describe you know if you loaded them
into a pandas dataframe and you said dot
described on all four of these you would
get basically the same numbers on all of
them and so that might lead you to say
like oh well then I'll use the same
model to predict the behavior of all
four datasets you would you would not do
so well using the same model on all four
of these data sets right they have
extremely different behavior but you
can't kind of tell that until you see
them right so I when I started thinking
about this more I started feeling like
the the solution to the informed machine
learning is hard problem is maybe
building in more more visualization and
you know I have this sort of concept of
doing machine learning in color
basically what i would like to show you
now is kind of what i think of is the
yellow brick road so it's a sequence you
know a set of kind of visualization you
know diagnostics visual Diagnostics that
you can deploy at multiple phases of the
machine learning pipeline to help you
kind of start to build intuition start
to say this is what's happening and this
is what's going wrong this is why this
is going wrong so that you can make
better decisions and iterate faster and
smarter
so in order to kind of get there though
I just want to use this term so I'm
going to explain that the model
selection triple basically is this
concept that machine learning is yes
it's definitely about selecting the
right model thank you stack overflow but
it's also about kind of feature
selection and feature analysis and also
about hyper parameter tuning so those
three things are sort of critical and so
the you know feature analysis part is
where you're starting to kind of figure
out what your where your signal is you
know what some of the problems might be
you know what's going to inform your
model what's going to be predictive
what's not going to be predictive model
selection you know ends up being about
you know picking the one model that
you're really good at tuning and then
only ever using that one just kidding ah
sorry that's what Stack Overflow will
tell you so you know it's about kind of
figuring out what you know what
algorithms sort of best captures the
specific behavior of your specific data
set meaning that it's not going to be
the same model every time and then hyper
parameter tuning so hyper parameters are
the parameters that you know so
scikit-learn has default hyper
parameters for all their models and you
know they'll set the alpha for you
they'll set the gamma the sea but if
you're not doing great and you use grid
search what's happening in grid search
is it's trying to optimize the hyper
parameters within some you know set
search space so that you can improve
your model performance so essentially
the you know the yellow brick road is
going to take us through the model
selection triple and so here are some
kind of examples so that first part the
visual future analysis getting started
with box plots is a really terrific kind
of starting point so right away you know
you can see that there are two of our
input features
that our way out of scale with the other
features so that gives us a lot of
information you know it takes an instant
to look at this and already you know
like maybe you want to do some sort of
standardization and normalization of
your your input histograms are also trip
with terrifically useful um you you know
basically hear you histogram it and your
leg please be a normal distribution and
if it is or close enough you know you
can sort of use a lot of the standard
models and if it's not you might need to
get a little bit creative or do some
more research into kind of trying to
figure out what's what's going on with
your your data and actually I should say
there's also one that I haven't included
here which is violin plots i'm not sure
if other people use violin plots but
basically it's like the best of both
worlds for box plots and histograms
because you get kind of the information
that that's encoded in both in a single
graph so slums i'm not sure if other
people use these or call them this but
this is a scatter plot matrix so we do
pairwise comparisons of the features so
you take two at a time and you pair them
up and graph them and what you're
looking for is like linear relationships
or quadratic relationships or maybe
you're looking for kind of how the
features are distributed relative to
each other so like homoscedasticity and
heteroscedasticity which starts to get
it you know problems like by a bias and
variance so you can you can see that
really early on before you do any
modeling at all joint plots so basically
you know sometimes your splunk it's a
little bit big and you need to have you
know something to focus down on and
that's what you know a joint plot it
basically is you know we're also getting
some we're getting kind of the kernel
density and the pearson coefficient with
this one i'm not sure if people use r
advies but r advies radial
visualizations are a great way to sort
of hunt for separable ax t in in
classification problems
so here you know the first thing that I
see is I'm starting to sense that you
know there is some distinction between
the blue dots and the orange dots it
makes me have some confidence that I'm
going to be able to separate them by
building some kind of classifier and
same thing with parallel coordinates so
you know whereas with rad vis you know
we've got our features plotted around
the unit circle and we let we let the
features pull the data points towards
them based on their normalized values
with parallel coordinates we have the
futures plotted on as you know parallel
lines here and each line segment
represents a single you know vector a
data point you know across the different
attributes and what you're looking for
is you know chords of color you know so
that's that says that the yellow class
you know there's a band a braid of color
there and there's maybe some braids of
blue that start to make you feel like
there is separable ax t here you know
that you you maybe can build a
classifier that's going to be able to
predict you know yellow and blue um so
for model selection probably some people
are familiar with this image yes so this
is the socket learn a kind of decision
tree flow diagram called choosing the
right estimator this is a terrific place
to get started I always point students
to this in the beginning because it is
an interactive walkthrough of kind of
interactive introduction walkthrough of
scikit-learn models with this sort of
decision making process factored in so
it asks you you know how much data do
you have how important you know are the
features are you trying to regress are
you trying to classify and so it takes
you through this decision and it ends up
pointing you to a model to try so this
is a great place to get started for
people who are a little bit more
experience with scikit-learn you know
that this is
little bit out of date it does not
represent all of the models that are
available in scikit-learn in fact it
doesn't represent you know most of the
bottles that are available in
scikit-learn and so you probably will
quickly exhaust this and kind of you
know be ready to go out and explore some
other models but you know it's a great
way to get started also part of
scikit-learn are these comparison plots
so there's the cluster comparison plot
and classifier comparison plot so you
know I don't see these as being things
you can really deploy on you know each
time you're building a model but I do
think you know if you're doing
clustering if you're doing
classification going back and looking at
these plots i think is really useful
because what you do is you start to be
able to visualize you know how these
algorithms carve up data space and they
do it very differently and so you know
it's not just you know when you're when
you're instantiate in a model you know
it's not just letters it's not just
words you know you want to start
thinking about how is the model that I'm
fitting and predicting on how does it
cut up the space and does that make
sense for the the data set that I've
just been visualizing using all these
these visual you know feature analysis
tools I've been sort of playing with
some other ways of kind of navigating
all of the different models that are
available I think Hadley Wickham has
this really great paper on removing the
blindfold I'm not sure if this is like a
Python group so of course you never read
anything about our but it's actually a
very good paper and one of the big
concepts in his paper is this notion of
models as being families forms and
fitted models models is an overloaded
term so models refers you know to
families of models like classification
you know naive Bayes models it also you
know refers to like the actual form of
the model so a model before its fit and
then the fitted model which means the
model that's already been you know the
parameters of our
been adjusted because you've called fit
on it already right so you know kind of
been thinking about how you know there
are different ways to represent the
models you know I'd be delighted to hear
you know if you've kind of come up with
other ways of navigating scikit-learn
models or other libraries models I think
another kind of you know another way to
approach model selection is just by
using all the models which you know
Nicole talked about in her talk
yesterday like why choose the model when
you can just use all the models and then
decide which one does the best and this
is a way to visualize how different
models are performing so instead of you
know working really hard to pick a model
in the beginning just use a lot of
models and then compare their their
classification heat map in the end so
this is you know just like kind of a
traditional confusion matrix or
classification report except that it's
overlaid with a heat map so you can kind
of quickly say like okay the darker
blues are the place where I'm performing
better the the lighter gray edge of the
places where I'm forming worse although
in the context of this one we're doing
pretty well we don't really have it's
probably made up data at least that I
generally don't do this well I'm just
going to be honest with you so you can
do and you can do something similar with
like ROC curves you can you know start
to visualize how your model is
performing and what I really like about
this visualization is starting to show
how you can use small multiples you can
compare models so this is comparing a
linear SVM and a que nearest neighbor
classifier and you can see that they
perform differently you know for
regression you can do something similar
you can compare you can use model
evaluation techniques to select the
model that's doing the best what's nice
about you know this so this is a
prediction error plot which is really
good for assessing you know how
regression models are doing you can
start to see not only which models are
doing better but you start to maybe see
why they're doing better so but
viduals is sort of just another you know
basically it's just another way of
looking at prediction error by looking
at you know the residuals and then
plotting here we've plotted the training
points against the test points so you
can see kind of how the different models
performs so for visual tuning you know
I'll remind you of kind of where we
started with hyper parameter tuning
where we're basically just using grid
search I'm saying you know search for me
figure it out optimize it and then just
tell me the answer so I don't have to
think about it the problem with that is
that in order to really do well with
grid search you already kind of have to
know the search space that you're
looking in or else it's going to run for
a very long time and maybe break your
computer so and I think what I would
sort of proposed is if you're trying to
figure out how to kind of explore your
your hyper parameters is to use
something like a validation curve we're
here what we're doing is we're exploring
a single hyper parameter across a range
of values and looking at how it impacts
the training and cross-validation scores
and so what we're looking for is like
kind of that optimal point where we
haven't over trained yet but you know
we're starting to get good
cross-validation scores another kind of
approach to this is using pairwise hyper
parameter tuning and this is what I sort
of think of is like a visual grid search
so here we r you know we're looking
across to hyper parameters and then
looking for the places where they
together result in the best performing
model
um so let's see okay just doing a time
check and so essentially i feel like
this gives you a lot you know these kind
of techniques they get you pretty far in
terms of starting to develop intuition
around machine learning the problem is
that those things that we just deployed
are spread out across a bunch of
different libraries right so some of
that is Matt plot live some of that is
pandas some of it is Seabourn so uh you
know it's really spread out it's not
very easy to kind of just build it into
your workflow and so what I started on
was building my first open source
project which is a project called yellow
brick and yellow brick is sort of an
attempt to reimplement a lot of these
these methods under a single API and
really the idea is that this is an API
that plays very nicely with psych it
learns API which is amazing I just like
I can't I can't overstate that like
scikit-learn API is terrific and what I
wanted to do was build in kind of just
that added layer of visualization so
that you could be exploring your
features and your model performance and
your hyper parameters and you could do
it all within kind of natively
scikit-learn workflows and so basically
you know the concept is that we've got
visual transformers right now in yellow
brick we have to to sort of components
that we've implemented we've got future
evaluation and model evaluation and what
you can do now is you can use yellow
brick to do things like searching for
separate e we've got our own pure map
hot Matt plot live implementations of
parallel coordinates and Rava's and
one of the things that we'll be able to
do soon is you'll actually be able to
interact with the attributes which you
can't do in any of the other
implementations that are available so
you'll be able to like pick up this
attribute and move it to a different
part and so so without that will do is
if two attributes are pulling in equal
and opposite directions and canceling
each other out you'll be able to flip
them and quickly see you know if there's
actually you know something interesting
there so I think that that will be you
know pretty exciting but for now you can
you know you can plot these natively in
Matt plot lab we have kind of our own
color scheme you can also do a couple of
things that are harder to do in other
libraries I'm not sure if other people
have explored rank 1 D and rank 2 D you
know this is kind of like a twist on the
slums but basically you know what we're
doing here is looking for you know for
signal right we're looking for you know
informative features and right now in
yellow brick you can do that in a couple
of different ways using a you know a
couple of different evaluation
techniques you can evaluate your models
so here are the examples for regressors
we also have classification heat maps
and rock out curves for classifiers and
we've also got few special things in
there to kind of help you start
identifying potential problems with your
data so this is a class balance report
so if you are kind of noticing you know
some strange performance with a
classifier you could call a class
balance a method and get a very quick
visualization of kind of what any
potential kind of imbalance problems are
um so I'm happy to say that as of about
an hour ago or 30 30 minutes ago maybe
you so so we deployed yellow brick to
the Python package index a very very
initial version a couple months ago we
just pushed 03 which is an alpha but you
can pep install it now I hope feel free
to try it now and see if it works yeah
so you can actually kind of start
engaging in this right away and by the
way if you are interested in engaging
with yellow brick I i made this plea
yesterday during the diversity luncheon
but I'm very interested in recruiting
testers so if you are a visualization
person and you're really you know you
like the visualization stuff you know
cut kind of sign up become a tester if
you're a machine learning person I
definitely sign up if you're kind of
neither and you're looking into getting
involved this is a great way to sort of
start learning about how to be a more
informed machine learning practitioner
if you are interested in contributing to
an open source project this is a this is
a way to become a named contributor to a
to a library so I'd be delighted for
people to kind of get involved and you
know I'm very excited about this project
I think you know one of the things that
I said yesterday that I want to kind of
reiterate is that this is the sort of
thing where your engagement will really
inform kind of where the package goes
it's in very early days and I think it
would be very interesting to hear from
you what kinds of visualization
techniques you've been using you know
it's part of your machine learning
workflows so that I can kind of know
about that we can think about it and
think about how we could build those in
and we implement them you know and kind
of integrate those in even if it's not
Python you know if you're an our user I
know there's a lot of interest in our
libraries for doing visualization so
definitely you know talk to me let me
know reach out become a tester I get
involved and you know again my name is
Rebecca bilbro I'm delighted that you
came to hear about my project and I'm
happy to take questions kind of now or
you know out in the hallway later or
you're welcome to tweet at me or you
know reach out through github or through
the the test reform which again is so
its bit ly /y be testers we're sort of
imagining like people you know import
yellow brick as why be so why be testers
for alpha testers and that's that's what
I got thanks very much
all those pretty color scheme those are
bacon and involves yes so you can check
out there's there's a couple of
different palettes that we've built I'm
just going to be honest with you and say
nobody who's currently working on the
project is a graphic designer so if
there are any people who are very good
at colors there's an issue especially
designed for you in the backlog I would
be delighted for you to check that one
out and make us some prettier colors but
basically what we're trying to do is
kind of have like the you know our own
spin on the traditional like you know
the single letter colors you know that
you know Seaborn has and Matt pot lab
has you know just so that it's easier
for a user to deploy colors using a
single letter and you know we want the
colors to be somewhat similar to what
their they'd be expecting from having
used other libraries but maybe have our
own kind of twist and you know if you
want to make it prettier like I'm I will
be happy to merge that sat in other
questions
depends entirely new project but aside
the documentation any other resources
recommend or oh that's a great question
um I'm my mic is like revolting against
me so um I there definitely is more to
learn about the project if you can visit
the district data labs website and so
it's ww district data labs com we have a
blog and there's a series of three blog
posts that go through in pretty deep
detail kind of the different parts of
you know the visualization pipeline that
are precursors you know they were sort
of part of the evolution of this this
project so they give you a lot of kind
of the rationale for some of the design
you know and implementation choices that
we've made so that's a great way to kind
of get like a quick and dirty
introduction and you know reach out and
you know after you read those reach out
and ask for more and I'll just it'll be
a steady stream of I'll never leave you
alone other questions would you say a
few words about district data laughs
what is that I'd be delighted to so um
the so district data labs is an open
source collaborative we all have day
jobs so I work at x cubed I'm the lead
data scientist there so that's how I pay
my mortgage and get by medicine and
stuff but district data labs is like my
mic didn't like that answer it wants me
to pay for things district data labs is
like my passion project so there's a
couple of folks here who are with
district data labs or kind of affiliated
with district data labs Nicole Allen
tony is our founder and not sure if
anyone else I'm not seeing you um
I you know essentially it's just a group
of people who really like building
things together we get together on the
weekends and at night after our kids go
to bed and we build projects and we try
to you know make make cool things and
put it out into you know into the world
and so sometimes that's open source
Python projects you know I think like
for Alan and I you know Nicole and I are
really interested in you know building
you know where we want to develop things
you know Tony is really interested in
kind of curating like thought leadership
and so he's put a lot of work into
making sure that we publish a lot of
ideas onto our blog so you can read
through you know code snippets and all
kinds of workflows and all kinds of
information on our blog and it's all
free and open everything we do is you
know out there you can go to our github
organization and there's a bunch of
repose that you can clone you can spin
off you know you can use however you
like you're welcome to contribute or
just to use it for yourself or something
cool and I'm let us know what you did
with it and that would be great oh yeah
we're definitely always looking for
people who want to you know join the
collaborative and work with us on
projects or do blog posts be delighted
to talk to you more about it if you know
if you want to other questions
well i think there's about five minutes
before be just doesn't like me there's
about five minutes before the lightning
talks start so I bet there's going to be
some really good one so if you would
like to go see those I won't feel bad if
you rush off to them but you know feel
free to reach out to me on Twitter or
through district data labs or through
our you know our test site I hope to
hear from you and see you around thanks
very much for coming